my next guest served for six years as a
US diplomat at the American Embassy in
Moscow he is co-author of the book roots
of Russia's war in Ukraine and he's a
senior fellow for Europe and Eurasia and
the American foreign policy Council I'm
happy to welcome to the day II Wayne
merry
mr. merry joins us tonight from our
studios in Washington mr. merry it's
good to see you how realistic do you
rank the claim that Russia was provoked
by Ukraine that Ukrainian ships provoked
Russia's Navy the term provocation is
used in that part of the world a great
deal I tend to not take it too seriously
I'm not saying however that this
incident is not serious and that it
could not lead to an escalation that is
certainly true unfortunately a
confrontation something like this in the
Straits of Kersh has been some has been
awaited by observers for many months the
problem is is that five years ago these
straits were an international border
between Crimea which was Ukrainian and
Russia after Russia seized an annexed
Ukraine Russia claims that these straits
are part of its own domestic internal
sovereignty Ukraine obviously disputes
that it doesn't accept the seizure of
Crimea and in its view Russia has no
sovereign claim to the these straits now
the two countries Russia and Ukraine
share the sea of azov and that's a
rather important waterway a great deal
of agricultural produce goes to the
Middle East through the sea of azov and
the Straits but what we have now is
simply a problem of rival claims of
sovereignty it's simple on it on its
face unfortunately what it means is that
at what whatever time Ukraine chose to
exercise its claim of sovereignty bait
which is supported by almost all
governments in the world other than
Russia
by sending
through those straits it would almost
certainly encounter a confrontation from
the Russians who claim that this is now
part of their internal waters I want to
draw your attention to what journalists
on the ground are writing about what's
happening yesterday the journalist Nolan
Petersen tweeted that this is the most
dangerous moment that I have seen in
Ukraine in years
tonight a war that many people in
America can only imagine thanks to
Hollywood movies teeters on the razor
thin edge of becoming real now do you
agree with him are we that close to a
full-fledged war that strikes me as a
considerable exaggeration because a war
has been ongoing in eastern Ukraine in
the Donbass region for over four years
now I was in the Donbass in April of
this year and I could tell you I could
hear the artillery in the distance at
night without difficulty and during the
day the visits that I had in some of the
areas along the line of fire required
body armor and helmets and and all that
sort of thing the war in the Donbass has
not gone away it's not as violent and
destructive as it was three or four
years ago but the notion that there is
not a war ongoing between Russian
support and separatists and often
Russian forces themselves in eastern
Ukraine against the sovereignty of the
Ukrainian government should not be
forgotten it's not that we are in danger
of a war we are in danger that that war
might move to a different location that
of the Kersh straits I want to draw your
attention to the statement that was
issued by ukrainian President poroshenko
today I mean this is part of a statement
that was issued to justify imposing
martial law but mr. poroshenko says that
Russia has been waging a hybrid war
against our country for five years but
with an attack on Ukrainian military
boats it moved to a new stage of
aggression no one will say now they are
not there I mean this is a qualitatively
different situation a qualitatively
different threat mr. merry how is this
so fundamentally different than what we
have seen I mean there was no martial
law declared in Ukraine in in the last
four or five years it correct me if I'm
wrong but we haven't seen marshal wall
up until tonight that is quite correct
at the time that Crimea was seized and
annexed by Russia
there was no declaration of martial law
the war in the Donbass and in Luhansk
which has been a very very violent war
by far the most violent war in Europe
since the yoga Slava's and in some
respects even more violent never
provoked martial law in Ukraine so far
the confrontation at the cursed rates
has not led to so far as we know a
single casualty the notion that somehow
that justifies martial law when a war
that has been going on and involving
human casualties human fatalities in the
dawn buskin Luhansk for over four years
never justified martial law really does
strain my credulity so what do you think
then president poroshenko was trying to
do here by imposing a martial law I mean
is he expecting no headwind at all from
Europe in the West because of this I
don't know I don't know what he's
expecting from Europe and the United
States what everyone in Ukraine is
expecting is that he's getting ready to
run for re-election as president of
Ukraine in the spring and almost
everyone who is not a supporter of
President poroshenko has been making
accusations that this martial law
question has been raised either to
inflame the political environment to
help his reelection
because he only gets about 10 percent
support in the polls or even more
potentially dangerous that he might use
martial law to seek either to delay or
to cancel those elections at the moment
it seems highly unlikely that poroshenko
could be a credible winner in those
elections
but I think actually he probably would
win the elections in some eventualities
but his opponents are saying that this
martial law issue is more about
Ukrainian domestic politics than it is
about the security threat on the edge of
the sea of us off and what about the
role of Germany in mediating between
Ukraine and Russia um we have heard many
many times about the special role of
Angela Merkel particularly leading up to
the Minsk agreement we now know that ms
merkel is going to be leading power so
how much Merkel is there left in any
type of mediation role well Chancellor
Merkel is not going to be leaving the
council erupt anytime soon so far as I
know I mean the whole question of her
future role as Chancellor is an open one
but it's both Germany and France who've
been playing the role of mediators in
the dispute between Ukraine and Russia
now they have not achieved a very great
deal of substance but that's because the
two main parties Russia and Ukraine have
not been willing to compromise their
objectives whether or not Chancellor
Merkel will play now an important role
on this current issue I don't know at
the moment the locus of discussion is in
New York at the UN Security Council
under the Charter provisions of
concerning threats to international
peace and security
as a former American diplomat who worked
in New York at the UN I think that's
exactly the appropriate location for an
incident of this kind well mr. mayor we
certainly appreciate you sharing your
insights with us tonight it is
invaluable to get the voice of
experience especially from someone with
the u.s. Foreign Service an experienced
diplomat you can talk to us and put some
context into all of this thank you we
appreciate it
let me let me Oh let me also say that
there is going to be an American issue
here okay I think this is almost
certainly going to lead to greater
pressure in the American Congress for in
handstand expanded sanctions against
Russia I think that's almost inevitable
okay well we if we may we'll try to call
you back later this week maybe we can
talk about that in another show this
week mr. Murray thank you very much we
appreciate your time
now let's get the Germans perspective on
this with me in is that good Krish bound
was a member of Angela Merkel's our
governing the CDU party he also chairs
the German parliament to a European
Affairs Committee and welcome to DW have
a good evening
what is Germany going to do about this
well we are deeply concerned about the
further developments here and we can
observe these tangents since a couple of
months especially in the region of the
SOC but what Russia did now can only
strongly be condemned it is an
aggression which does not help because
we have these tensions and now mr.
poroshenko announced today the law the
war law and this does not help when we
come and we want to calm down the
situation so we ask also to de-escalate
now the situation and but Russia is in
the role they have to act and not in a
military sense that's quite clear so I
hope that it will be possible if both
sides are reasonable now and perhaps
also with France and Germany as an
honest broker in this situation to calm
down the situation and but finally and
this has to be emphasized to once again
the C the SOC can be used by both
nations by Ukraine and Russia we have a
treaty since 2003 and this was violated
by Russia okay so this all sounds very
reasonable use you you say that Germany
wants to see a de-escalation of this
issue and what everybody should be
to acted reasonably Russia has
demonstrated time and time again that it
is not prepared to act reasonably so
once Germany has called for
de-escalation and being ignored what
then well for
it will be discussed now in the Security
Council in you and the Security Council
and that's the right place and it should
not be excluded that also further
sanctions can be now happened towards
Russia I want to avoid it but that's
exactly the point
Russia has to be reasonable because
another wall will not help for the whole
region because we need stability and
also Ukraine needs stability but there's
one point very very clear this crisis
now was cost and reached by Russia
so has what is angular Merkel been in
touch with anyone on this issue Angela
Merkel is in a close touch with the
Ukrainian authorities and especially
also with France because I think we has
we have this framework of Minsk which
you can't no one cares about Minsk Minsk
it keeps getting ignored I think it is
there it's a light contradiction from my
point of view because it's necessary to
continue this dialogue because a
military option will not be helpful we
have now the economic sanctions we had
the pressure on Russia and Russia cannot
be interested in all these sanctions
because they need also the talking to
technology they normally buy in Western
Europe
other than the Western world because
they don't have this innovation in their
own country so that's really violating
their own economy yes you say that
except that what we keep seeing is
Russia says we want that the world set
including Germany says no no no no no be
reasonable Russia says no it's ours
Russia tastes it the world goes let's be
reasonable let's talk let's have a new
go see a ting process and Russia says
yeah you talk you have your negotiating
process this is ours and it stays ours
no because it's not up to Russia to calm
down the situation they provoked it no
chaos they provoked it why should it
calm down when when when what we have
seen clearly is that Russia has decided
this is our backyard this is what we
want the world keeps
to Russia you need to canvassed and the
world keeps imposing sanctions on Russia
and Russia keeps saying this is ours we
don't care in this case they can't say
it's ours because the sea of azov
there we have to respect also
international law and we have the sea
borders that's all international rule
and it's an international law so this
cannot be avoided from the point of
Russia and it cannot be denied from from
the Russian side so I think
international pressure is needed and
look on the on the economic side of
Russia look on the economic development
Russia does not real and cannot have
real interest at the moment because when
you look on the internal situation now
in moscow putin tried to develop a
pension reform and he got a lot of
protests in the streets and a lot of
protests for our from the concern people
so there's also a lot of internal
pressure in russia which is perhaps
sometimes not seen so that's my point of
view because then i say it cannot be an
interest in a deep interest of Russia to
get more international pressure to get
more international sanctions but it is
perfectly these sanctions will be the
consequence if Russia will not if Russia
will continue what they did and that's
also why I'm asking that they have to
release also the three captures captured
soldiers or better to say cement sailors
because that's not acceptable
well let us hope that you are right and
that cooler heads prevail thank you so
much for joining us sir thank you for to
khushbu thank you thank you you're
welcome